WILLIAM LI: So the class
was started in 2011.
That was the first
time it was offered
in the fall semester of 2011.
It was founded by
Professor Seth Teller, who
has done a lot of work over
the past couple of decades,
particularly in computer
vision and in robotics.
And over time I think he saw
that a lot of the work that he
was doing could also be
applicable to assistive
technology or
technologies that can
help people with disabilities
live more independently
or help them in their
day-to-day lives.
So I think over the
past maybe decade
or so, he's been involved
in a lot of course creation
and creating robotics courses
and other undergraduate
courses in electrical
engineering, computer science.
And I think that this
class was in a lot
of ways kind of an extension
to that to some extent,
focused on assistive technology.
Over the years, I
think Seth had a chance
to work in assistive
technology in research projects
and then interact a lot with
people with disabilities
in the Cambridge area
or the Boston area
and really get a sense of the
kinds of practical challenges
that they face and how
technology could help.
So that really I think
was the motivation
for starting the
class, trying to work
with this group of
people and also to tap
into the interest of
undergraduate students
to work on service
learning projects
or to apply their design and
engineering skills to something
meaningful.
So he taught this class
of the past three years,
and we're fortunate to
be teaching it this fall.
GRACE TEO: In terms of
departmental support
for the class, so because
Professor Teller was part
of the electrical engineering
and computer science
department at MIT, that's
mainly where it has been housed
for the last three and this
year as well-- so four years--
going forward, we're
actually looking
to cross list a class between
electrical engineering
and computer science,
mechanical engineering,
as well as health
sciences and technology.
And so I would say
that when it was housed
within electrical engineering
and computer science,
we had a lot of computer
science students come to us.
And so a lot of
the other projects
ended up being
software-related projects,
because that was
their skill set,
and that's what they
were comfortable with.
But we've also seen that a
lot of assistive technology
requires hardware design
as well, and so that's
why we're bringing in
mechanical engineering
support for the class.
And as for health sciences and
technology, their role at MIT
is really to serve
as this integrated
force between different
facets of engineering
and the medical community.
And so what we're hoping to
do next year with HSTS, Health
Science and
Technology Support, is
to bring in occupational
therapists into the class
as well to help the students
with their projects.
So yeah.
Just in thinking about the
different skill sets that
go into the projects, we do
think software, hardware,
and then being able to interface
with the health side of things
is very important.